the anger over president Trump's
reported vulgar talk on immigration is
now closer to forcing a government
shutdown Congress needs to pass some
kind of spending bill by Friday but now
that is in jeopardy over GOP plans to
phase out the daca program that protects
young undocumented immigrants Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill Nancy good
morning
good morning and some Democrats are
saying they will not vote to fund the
government at the end of this week
unless Republicans embrace a bipartisan
solution for the so-called dreamers
young people who were brought to this
country illegally and that is raising
the possibility of the first government
shutdown since 2013 I urged the
president to lead us to that bipartisan
solution mr. president closed the deal
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham called
on the President to broker a solution
for daca that also fixes a broken
immigration system it's not going to be
done on Twitter by tweeting it's going
to be done by talking to President Trump
returned from his Florida resort to a
feud in Washington over the future of
the dreamers and a government funding
deadline a bipartisan group of senators
did reach agreement on a replacement for
daca last week we prepared a bill a
bipartisan bill that hit all four
elements the president asked for and the
president said he'd sign a bill brought
to his desk I'm not going to say oh gee
I want this right what that I'll be
signing it but that's the deal the
president rejected in that now-infamous
meeting where he referred to some
Caribbean and African countries as
expletive holes the exact word used by
the president mr. Trump tweeted on
Monday that Illinois Democrat dick
Durbin totally misrepresented what was
said in that meeting and that Durbin
blew daca I stick with my original
interpretation Durbin says a divided
over immigration policy is the real
problem if the president will keep his
word as of last Tuesday if he'll move
forward and endorse this bipartisan
agreement we can get this done this week
some Democrats believe a government
funding bill is the leverage they need
to demand a compromise on dreamers
Senate Republicans need at least nine
Democratic votes to pass and
measure to fund the government past this
Friday's deadline Republicans warn that
if there is a government shutdown
Democrats would get the blame and
privately some Democrats worry about
that possibility the best hope for some
kind of bipartisan solution now appears
to be John the talks that are quietly
going on between the number two Democrat
and Republican in the House and Senate
but they're gonna have to come up with
something pretty quickly and then
convince the president thanks so much
Nancy